Let's take a look at how sound works. Now say a bird starts singing
[SOUND]
and this travels through the air as a sound wave before reaching the ear. The
sound wave is a analog signal, but in order to represent it on a computer we
need to convert it to digital information. After it's converted to digital, we
might want to perform some audio transforms on it. To change the volume.
[NOISE]
Or apply some other echo effect.
Or something much more complicated and awesome
[NOISE].
We can think of all these transforms as a graph of processing notes that each
transform our sound in some way. And you can put them together, and that's
exactly how Web Audio is structured. In this case, you can take this sound, run
it through a series of nodes to transform it into, for example, a slap-back
echo effect. Let's take a look at the Web Audio Playground, which is a web
application built by Chris Wilson. It's a great way to visualize how Web Audio
works and you can actually play around with all the different nodes, you can
create source nodes and add all these different processing nodes to your
sounds. And you can create that same slap-back effect like this
[SOUND].
Now, Web Audio is a node graph that is contained in something called an audio
context. Everything in the audio context is run natively in high performance
code, specifically designed for audio processing. Of course, what we see here
is a simple example, a real node graph may look quite complicated, but
ultimately it's all using the same concepts.